The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Today, we're
talking about energy demand.
I do owe you 2 pictures however,
which I will now supply.
The first is-- that's
Bangladesh as it
is today with 112
million people,
and as it would be with a meter
and a half sea level rise,
about 17 million people
or 15% of the population
live in the areas
that would be flooded.
A meter and a half
may be a little
aggressive over the century,
but it's within the bounds
that people talk about.
They talk about a meter,
meter and a 1/2, sometimes 2.
So that's Bangladesh.
This if it comes out,
this is a picture
that I promised
you to talk about--
radiative forcing and methane
here versus carbon dioxide.
So this is a 2007 study that
looks at total contribution
to increased radiative
impact between 1750 and 2005.
You will see up here, CO2 has
a much bigger estimated effect
than methane.
And the molecules last a lot
longer in the atmosphere.
So each methane molecule,
as Susan Solomon said,
is more powerful.
But half of these will
be gone in 10 years.
Whereas ballpark, half
of these will still
be around in a century.
So there are clear reasons for
focusing on carbon dioxide.
The halo carbons
are fluorocarbons,
chlorofluorocarbons
and the like.
They are very powerful,
and they last a long time.
But they're not
greatly abundant.
And people are working
to phase them out.
Somebody mentioned black carbon.
There's a black carbon
impact via the reflectivity,
the albedo.
It does have a positive impact,
land use, negative impact
and so forth.
Aerosols are interesting.
This is like sulfur
dioxide put in the air
by coal-fired power plants.
That reflects, so
that tends to cool.
When Mount Pinatubo
blew in the Philippines,
there was I think about a
two degree impact on climate
from basically all that
dust reflecting sunlight.
So that's the best estimate.
It appears lots of places
of the cumulative impact
of human activity.
1750 is usually taken
as pre-industrial times,
kind of the benchmark.
Does this make some sense?
Are there questions about it?
OK, hearing none.
Today, I want to talk
about energy demand.
We'll also talk
about it Wednesday
but from a rather
different point of view.
I want to talk about
where it comes from,
the sort of short run,
long run difference.
How you might estimate
characteristics
of energy demand and then
stability and some puzzles.
So this is basically going to
be a walk through that teaching
note.
So it's fairly basic,
fairly basic stuff.
With very few exceptions,
there is no demand for energy.
There's a demand for
what energy does.
I mean you don't buy gasoline
to have it around the house.
Gasoline is nasty.
Vapors are explosive.
You buy it for what
you can do with it.
The demand for gasoline
is derived from what
it does, what it does for you.
And if you think about all the
things you use energy for, I
mean, you use it to heat food.
You use it to heat the house.
You use it to cool.
You use it to make loud music.
Energy does a lot of things.
You don't actually want to run
electricity through your body,
you want to use it to drive
speakers and so forth.
So the question is, if it's
that kind of a commodity,
how do we think
about it's demand?
Where does it come from?
It's clear that to produce any
energy service, heat, cooling,
transportation, it comes
with a bunch of inputs,
like any other product.
Transportation will
involve capital
in the form of some
kind of vehicle,
driving energy,
in this case, not
materials other than gasoline.
But well, maybe spare
parts, oil, and so forth.
So you start with that.
And I just make this
interesting point
that you normally
think of inputs
into production as substitutes.
So if capital gets more
expensive, you use more labor.
You switch from
capital to labor.
Well, capital and
energy has turned out
in a number of studies
to be complements,
which is pretty rare.
If you raise the
price of energy,
you reduce the
demand for energy.
You reduce the
demand for capital
used in production as well, OK.
I will talk about this last
point in a minute, the progress
in these production functions.
Clear so far?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Sorry, what example?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Materials.
That's just a general form
of a production function.
If you want to
produce cooked food,
you need some piece
of capital to contain
the heat, some source of
heat, your cooking time,
and of course, the ingredients.
So that would be
an example where
it would be important, OK?
This is just some indication.
There's a Nordhaus paper I
think I cited in the note that
looks at the cost of lighting.
Cents per 1,000 lumens
from 1800 to today.
And it's dramatic.
You can actually do
light because you
can look at the output of
various lighting devices.
You're doing whale oil
up here and so forth.
And it does get a little flat.
Once you get the fluorescent
bulbs, it gets flat.
And we're down here beginning
to think about LEDs.
But it's also true
in automobiles.
I don't have the slide, but
2.6% of the year advance
in automotive technology
estimated by my colleague,
Chris Knittel, means that--
well, here's one example
of what it means.
If you kept all the
other characteristics
of an automobile at
1980 levels, we'd
have a 50% increase
in miles per gallon,
or decrease in gallons per
mile between 1980 and 2006.
In fact, we didn't.
Mileage was pretty stable and
all these things increased.
But 2.6% a year is a
pretty dramatic increase
in the advance of a
very mature technology.
And you see this in a lot
of energy using technology.
Power plants have
this lighting, motors,
lots of energy
using technologies,
air conditioners have
this kind of progress
that energy per unit of
output has fallen dramatically
historically.
All right, so let me do a
little bit of characteristics
of derived demand.
Because when you think about
energy, energy demand, you do
need to kind think about
it as derived demand.
So let's suppose
capital is fixed.
It's the short run.
I'm going to just lay
this out for the moment.
Yep, so we want to drive
the demand for gasoline.
We want to think
about where it comes
from, or the demand for gas to
dry clothes, or to cook food.
There is sort of two
functions involved.
The first is some demand
function for the service.
What am I willing to pay
to have my condo cool?
That's going to depend on
the cost of cooling it,
other prices, how wealthy
I am, capital stock
tastes, all kinds of things.
But I'm going to focus on
the relation between how
cool I keep it, my
demand for cooling,
and what does it
cost me to cool?
What it costs me to cool comes
out of how I produce cooling.
There's some production function
determined by my very old air
conditioner that I'll
get cooling services.
It will depend on, well, in
this case not particularly
materials or labor.
It's just going to depend on
how much electricity I use.
So in the case of cooling,
this function gets simple.
The cooling, however
we measure it
is going to be a function
of how much energy,
how much electricity I use.
We could get fancy.
It will depend on when
I use it and so forth.
But as a simple story,
that's a pretty good story.
So if what I'm interested in
is the demand for electricity
as a function of its
price, then somehow I
don't have a price
for cooling, right?
I don't pay.
I don't get a bill
to cool my apartment.
I get a bill for electricity.
So if I want to get a
demand for electricity
as a function of its
price, I need these.
I need this function.
How much do I care
about cooling?
And this function,
how do I get cooling?
And then obviously, something
about the price of electricity.
So I'll tell you how
you do it in general,
and then we'll walk
through an example.
And there's some
stuff in the notes.
So if I've got all the
prices, conceptually I
say, well, what's the best
way to produce cooling?
That is a function of
prices, prices of the way
down here rather.
If I know the prices of energy,
the price of anything else I
use, I can say, what's
the cost of cooling
as a function of various prices?
Then I can substitute
the cost of cooling,
the price of the service
up here and get the demand.
That's impossible to follow.
Am I right?
OK.
You'll come back to
it after the example.
So let's do lighting with
two very simple functions.
Suppose up here is my
demand for lighting.
So lumen hours,
which I'm just going
to call lumens to keep my
slides a little shorter,
my bullet's a little shorter.
Lumen hours, this is my demand.
If this is the cost
per lumen hour,
then with A and B as
constants, then this
is my demand per lumen hour.
It's a straightforward
demand curve.
B is the price elasticity.
You may remember that from
first economics course.
It's the ratio of
percentage changes.
Limiting ratio is
the changes go to 0,
the percentage change in demand
induced by a 1% change in cost,
or an epsilon change
in cost, the ratio.
We use elasticities a lot in
economics just as a reminder
because they are unit free.
There's no natural units here.
So you could measure price in
pennies or dollars or euros
or whatever else.
So you don't want to say the
notion of change per dollar
doesn't have any particular
intrinsic meaning.
The notion of percentage change
from a 1% increase in cost
is usually a little
more convenient.
So let me suppose that's my
demand curve for lighting.
And let me suppose
it's the short run.
So again, the more electricity
I use, the more lighting I get.
And e is just some constant.
So now what I want
to know, I want
to get my demand for
electricity for lighting, right?
It's a derived demand.
I don't care about electricity.
I care about lighting,
about L. I use electricity
to produce it.
The demand for lighting
is derived from the demand
for electricity.
So how do I do it?
OK, in this simple case, if
I've got a price of electricity,
say dollars per kilowatt
hour, I could easily
solve with this thing
for a price per lumen.
I know what electricity costs.
I know the relation between
electricity and lumens,
it's linear.
So I know the price,
lumen hours, but lumens.
So just to get
the unit straight,
the units of this
little constant e
has to be lumen hours
per kilowatt hour, right?
And I want a price per lumen.
So I get $1 per lumen price by
dividing the per kilowatt hour
price by lumens
per kilowatt hour.
So I've now got the
cost per lumen hour, OK?
With me so far?
Scream and shout if not.
Well, don't scream, but
a shout would be good.
I can substitute then.
I know that the
amount of lumens I get
is this little constant e times
the amount of electricity.
The demand curve then
is A times the dollars
per lumen to the minus
B. That's dollars
per lumen, PE over little e.
Solve for electricity, and I
have the demand for electricity
as a function of its price, OK?
Walk one more time.
I care about lighting
as a function
of the cost of lighting.
I don't care about electricity.
I care about lighting as
a function of its cost.
What I want to do
first is get the cost.
And in this case, because it's
the short run and very simple,
all the bulbs are fixed.
It's just proportional to
how much electricity I use.
So the cost-- you can think of
e as relating to efficiency.
You increase little
e, basically,
I've got more
efficient bulbs, which
is another way to get quickly.
I do it with units because
otherwise I get backwards.
But the larger is this
efficiency parameter little
e given the electricity price,
the cheaper is lighting, right?
So it's another way
to think about it.
Once I have the
cost of lighting,
I can substitute into
the demand function.
Note that here is the
production function.
Take this second to
quality and solve.
And I get the demand
for electricity
is a function of the
price of electricity
and the efficiency of lighting.
Question, is this easy?
Hard?
Confusing?
Backwards?
Upside down?
Will it be on the quiz?
Yeah, probably.
Yeah, something like it.
Yeah.
Julian, Julian,
you had a question?
AUDIENCE: Oh, no, I was
giving you a thumbs up.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: You
give me a thumbs up, OK.
This is a rare and
wonderful experience.
Let me just treasure
this for a moment.
Does anybody have an alternative
reaction of any kind.
OK, all right, I move on.
A couple of comments about this.
Think about that function.
You know, I really should
have put it on this slide.
You notice a couple of things.
You'll notice that the
elasticity of demand
for electricity turns out to
be the same as the elasticity
of demand for lighting.
That is not a general property.
It can be greater or less.
It's not a general property.
You will also notice
that what happens
to the demand for electricity
when efficiency increases
depend on that parameter B. So
that if B is greater than 1,
then making my light
bulbs more efficient
will increase my use
of electricity, right?
Because B greater than 1
means my demand for lighting
is really price sensitive.
And if you've made
lights more efficient,
you've reduced the
cost of lighting.
And since my demand for
lighting is price sensitive,
you make lights more efficient.
I use more lighting, OK.
Those are basically
the two comments.
The first is that
relationship, it's
kind of a function
of this example.
The second comes up in
debates about auto efficiency
standards.
Because it makes
sense, if I impose
a miles per gallon
standard on cars,
I have made driving
less expensive.
And if driving is
really price sensitive,
that could on balance increase
the demand for gasoline.
Now, this gets debated.
This is called
the rebound effect
in talking about CAFE standards,
auto fuel efficiency standards.
Most estimates say
that it happens.
But as far as CAFE standards
are concerned, in effect,
B is less than 1.
The rebound effect is small.
But it's there.
Estimates show it to be
there because driving
is price sensitive.
Price of gasoline goes
up, people drive less.
Cars get cheaper to
drive, people drive more.
Not a big effect, not a
huge effect, but it's there.
OK so far?
Very quiet today, OK.
All the enthusiasm went
into negotiations then, OK.
Obviously price isn't the
only thing that matters.
I find a very interesting graph.
This is passenger kilometers
traveled per capita
on the vertical axis.
It's a log, log scale.
And GDP per capita
on the horizontal
axis, you will notice that
the relation looks linear.
What you can't see
is that this is
a scatter that includes all
kinds of different countries,
sub-Saharan Africa, Latin
America, North America.
The universe is somewhere
in this scatter over time.
So this is probably
North America.
It points to a relatively
constant elasticity.
That's not driven,
that's traveled.
So you get airplanes at
the top, and so forth.
There is this law, and I don't
remember the parameter that
says you spend x%
your time traveling,
whether you're a poor person
walking or a rich person
flying, the travel
percentage turns out
to not vary much with income.
That's a big income effect.
Let me just say that.
That's an income elasticity
floating around 1,
double income, double
vehicle miles traveled.
It doesn't necessarily
mean double gasoline,
doubling anything else,
people travel other ways.
But income affects energy
demand, obviously, a lot.
What about the long run?
Well, when I talked about
the demand for lighting
or the demand for
driving or anything else,
in that simple example, or
in the example in the note,
you hold the
capital stock fixed.
In the longer run,
and here gasoline
is the thing to think
about, I'll change my car.
So in the short run,
price of gasoline moves.
Maybe I drive a little more.
Maybe I drive a little less.
Price of gasoline goes up by a
multiple of 5 and stays there,
let's say.
I probably would change my car.
I might want to consider
changing where I live.
I might want to rethink my
use of public transportation.
I can do a lot of things
in the longer run.
I can certainly change my car
and think about where I live.
Do I really want to live in
Weston as opposed to-- oh,
you're not from here.
Do I really want to live
way out in the suburbs
if gasoline is really expensive.
Or do I want to think
about moving into town.
And if I'm locating a factory,
and I'm thinking about,
do workers like to drive very
far, or an office building,
I have to rethink
where to put it.
So in the longer run,
you expect more change.
You expect whatever the
response to an energy price
changes in the
short run, bip, bip,
bip, you expect if
it's maintained,
the response will be longer.
That will be larger.
And I will come back to this.
This is sort of a
basic principle.
Paul Samuelson was the
first to really lay it out.
You have more flexibility in
the long run, more things,
more degrees of freedom.
You expect a greater
response to almost anything,
income change, price
change, whatever,
if it's maintained over time.
You expect the response
to grow to a change that's
maintained over time.
Part of that is because
of the long-lived capital.
But you will also recall that
we talked about all kinds
of path-dependent reasons.
So let me just slip
outside economics for just
a slight moment and say that
for the pure economic side, one
reason why the long
run response is greater
than the short run response
is because you change capital
stock.
And you don't change
capital stock quickly.
At the societal
level, the things
that affect response may
be policies, may be habits,
may be culture.
And they change very quickly.
For Boston to look
like Copenhagen
as far as bicycle
usage is concerned
would not be easy or quick.
They're having ferocious
debates about how
to set up the Longfellow bridge
for bicycles versus cars.
And that bridge hasn't been
reconfigured in 100 years.
It will now have, I think, more
bicycle space going forward.
And if you've biked
across that bridge,
you will think
that's a good thing
because it's a little tricky--
so long run, short run.
So let me now talk about how
you estimate these things.
So that's theory.
I'm a rational
calculator, I'm Walmart,
and I want to know my
demand for electricity
for heating and cooling.
I don't care about electricity.
I care about
heating and cooling.
I want to think through how
my demand for electricity
will be reflected by
changes in the price.
And I will look at my
production function,
the HVAC system I've got.
And I'll look at
my demand function,
how much do I care
about store temperature
and figure out what I want to
do in terms of electricity.
And then in the
longer run, depending
on the cost of electricity,
I will insulate more or less.
I will design stores
in different ways.
I have all kinds of
response options.
So that's terrific for
the decision maker.
Suppose you want to estimate
the demand for electricity,
the demand for
gasoline or anything
else by looking at the market.
You're a seller.
You're a policymaker.
You care about what
all of that stuff
ends up looking like at
the end of the day when
all the decisions shake out.
So a natural thing to
do is to look at data.
The first place this was
done was in agriculture.
People said well,
you know, we'd like
to know what the demand
curve for wheat looks like,
what the demand
curve for corn looks
like for planning purposes.
If you've seen the
Department of Agriculture
building in Washington,
it was for a long time
the largest building
in the world.
We spend a lot of effort
studying agricultural markets.
And when they
first did this they
found demand curves
that sloped up.
They graphed price, and
they graphed quantity,
and they got demand
curves sloping up.
This was disturbing.
How could that happen.
Yes, Marie.
AUDIENCE: Well, the
demand curve could
shift with the supply curve.
And if they shift more
easily, you might a bad--
your data is not going to
follow the trend of specifically
the demand curve.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: OK, close.
You're saying that
the data are going
to be affected by the supply
curve as well as the demand
curve.
In fact, suppose the supply
curve doesn't shift at all.
What are you going to get?
AUDIENCE: If the supply curve
doesn't shift at all then
you're going to get
every change in--
like the equilibrium
point is going
to be a point along
the demand curve.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Think again.
The supply curve doesn't shift,
the demand curve does shift.
What do you get?
AUDIENCE: You are going to
trace out the supply curve.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
You're going
to trace out the supply
curve, which is what
David was dying to say, right?
Am I right?
OK.
We're going to
move to thumbs, OK?
The classic picture, the classic
picture, so you have what's
come to be called an
Identification problem.
How do you figure out,
how do you get to demand?
I care about demand.
I'm not getting demand.
I'm getting supply.
And in fact, if
that's the world,
if all I know were
price and quantity,
and all I know is the
demand curve shifts
and the supply curve doesn't,
I can't estimate demand.
That's to say, it's
not identified.
I could gather all the data in
the world from that setting.
And I could not learn
about demand from the data.
Demand curve is not identified.
So what you need--
and Marie was on to it.
What you need is you've got
to move the supply curve.
There has to be something
that affects supply.
If you've got something
that affects supply,
and you've got something
that affects demand and they
both move around,
then if you work
through the example
in the teaching note,
you can, in principle
estimate both of them.
There are nice techniques.
This is a lot of fun.
But I mention this not
because this course
is about learning these
techniques, which it's not,
but it is about being skeptical
when people tell you, well, we
plotted price and
quantity and we
got-- here's our demand curve.
Whenever you're dealing with
a demand supply situation,
you have to ask, how do you
know that you're actually
getting demand not
supply not some mixture?
Right?
You can have both demand
and supply shifting,
and you could get
a scatter of points
that slopes down or is flat.
You could say, well, you know,
demand is very price elastic
because the scatter shows this.
Well, it doesn't.
This is just a caution.
Because you will
see in your life,
I expect, with
reasonable probability,
estimates of the demand for
this and the demand for that.
And question one, is how do
you know you've got demand?
What did you do to deal with
this identification problem?
What did you do to
deal with the fact
that demand and supply are
simultaneously determined?
OK, clear, simple,
classic stuff, OK.
Now, I talked about the
long run and the short run.
So how do we do
that in practice?
Well, there's a simple way
that's pretty commonly used.
And it's called a
partial adjustment model.
And the equation let's say,
E is the demand for energy.
And here all the things
that determine it.
E star is a function.
E star is considered to be
the long run demand function.
And lambda is a constant
between 0 and 1, OK?
So this is a common formulation.
If you think about it and
you fiddled with difference
equations, or you
can just substitute,
suppose E star is constant.
Suppose the demand
for energy is constant
because the prices and
other things have changed,
and they've changed permanently.
Then E is going to
converge to E star.
Again, you just start out at
some E0 and just substitute.
And you will see that if
lambda is less than 1,
the initial condition goes away
and it converges to E star.
So this is a model.
But in the short run, in the
short run, the change in demand
will be reduced by this
multiple lambda, right?
So suppose doubling
income doubles E star.
OK, that's the
long run response.
If lambda is 0.5, then
doubling income today
will by itself only increase
energy by 50% of E star, right?
So it's a smoothing.
You could think about this
as smoothing as signal
detection is whatever you like.
But the effective
lambda less than 1
is that the response
in the short run
is less than the
response in the long run.
So you estimate that.
You assume a function
that involves everything
else you can think of.
You use some technique
to deal with the fact
that price is determined along
with quantity, along with E
and estimate a function of that
form, pretty commonly done,
pretty commonly done.
I'm going to give you some
actual estimates in a minute.
They tend to come from a
framework like that where you
say, it's a simple way of
saying if a change is maintained
over time, the response
will be greater
than if the change happens today
and gets reversed tomorrow.
It has that property for
lambda between 0 and 1, OK?
Yeah, that's all
straightforward.
You can recover so to speak.
You estimate a
function like this
that has lagged demand
on the right as well.
Its coefficient is an
estimate of 1 minus lambda.
That lets you recover lambda.
That lets you get the
long run function, right?
So if I want to know what
the long run response is,
I look at the lag
dependent variable.
And again, if you
think about it,
suppose this coefficient is 0.9.
That means all else
equal, E is going
to tend to be pretty
smooth, right?
The changes in E star are
going to be highly damp.
This will be 0.1.
And E itself is going
to be pretty smooth.
But I can sort of undo
that by saying, all right,
I'll divide by 0.1
over here and get
an estimate of the function
that would govern response
to permanent changes, OK?
There are other approaches.
There's a note, the note cites
this very interesting paper
by Hill Huntington that
looks at oil price changes.
He notes that the price
of oil at any time
is equal to the sum of the
maximum it's ever been.
And the difference
between what it is today
and the maximum it's ever been.
He puts both of these
into an equation
and finds that the maximum has
the largest negative effect
on demand for gasoline.
In his argument--
so it's not this.
It's a different
adjustment mechanism.
He says people get a
sense of what kind of cars
they ought to have
and how they ought
to heat their houses based on
how high oil or gasoline has
been.
So the previous maximum has
a very powerful shock impact.
We do remember gasoline
prices over $4 a gallon.
You may be able to say what
it is right now, I can't.
So P max the argument
is has a large effect.
I'm not sure that's right.
I haven't seen any other study
that tested that effectively
or that reproduced it.
But it it's an
interesting approach.
Most of the time,
again, the intuition,
because all this
stuff is durable,
all these assets are durable,
changes take a long time, OK.
Some results, this is
something that people
have studied a lot, the demand
for various forms of energy.
And I will have
assigned a paper or two.
But they all go properly
into the deep weeds,
technically, and
in terms of data.
So I'm just going to
give you a summary.
The first summary
point is the difference
is normally huge between the
short run and the long run.
So to go back to that
other formulation,
it's as if lambda
is generally quite
small in models like that,
estimated to be quite small.
Second, short run income and
price elasticity, say a year,
is generally less than 0.5.
So if you double price,
you will reduce consumption
by less than half.
I mean generally, you
will see a good deal less,
double income price
consumption will
increase by less than half.
The results seem to
depend on the economy,
rich countries, poor countries.
That might make
some sense, density.
You can think of
all kinds of things
that might affect
how people respond
to changes in price and income.
A lot of the studies have been
of gasoline and electricity.
And here's some of the
ranges for elasticities.
Income elasticity is
the percentage increase
in demand by 1%--
small 1%-- increase in income.
So income elasticity of 1
means if I double your income,
you double your demand.
The short run elasticities
for gasoline--
yeah, the short run
price elasticities
for gasoline and electricity
tend to be quite low.
Just looking at
the literature, I
think that the studies
tend to cluster more
toward the low end
of those ranges.
So price elasticity of 0.1
means I double the price.
Consumption goes down by 10%.
0.2 means 20%.
So these are small responses.
These are low elasticities.
Notice there's a
big difference--
factor of 2, 2 and 1/2 there.
Bigger in gasoline
than electricity,
which makes a little more
sense but only a little.
The income elasticity
of electricity I'm
going to return to.
In the long run, that's
tended to be pretty high.
Most estimates say,
as people get richer,
they use more electricity.
And it's plus or minus
proportional to income.
You add appliances,
bigger house.
All the things that
take electricity
tend to go up with income.
And that affect is not small.
In the short run, well,
that's pretty small, right?
I mean.
My income goes up
significantly in the short run.
What do I use electricity for?
It's mostly related.
These are residential,
mostly residential.
There's relatively
little I can change
until I start changing assets.
So it makes sense
that again, there's
a big long run, short-run gap.
What's interesting here is
the long-run elasticities
are pretty big historically.
Yeah, Andrew.
AUDIENCE: Do these numbers--
they seem to take on something
from the '70s to now.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: No, I'm
going to come right to that.
The width of those ranges ought
to tell you that these are not
constants of nature.
This is a summary of human
behavior, human behavior
changes.
So they do change over time.
And the problem,
there is a piece
I could have assigned
because it's pretty simple.
There's a piece
that's argued, there's
been a big change in the
price elasticity of demand
for gasoline in the '80s.
And I'm trying to remember
whether it goes up or down.
So people have looked at
this, but not much, not much.
You just see different
studies from different periods
and in different countries
getting different results.
And you say, well, maybe
that's a change in reality
or maybe that's a
different method, right?
It depends on data.
It depends on, can
you study households?
Is this aggregate data?
What are you working with?
But I want to make
a couple of points
about this stuff being
constants of nature.
This is one of the
interesting puzzles.
This is electricity demand.
And if you look at electricity
use in the United States
before about 1970, you get
sort of the top two rows.
You get pretty
good growth in GDP.
And these are not per capita.
So this is total
electricity use, total GDP.
That's pretty good annual
growth rates, 3 and 1/2, 4,
and very big growth
rates in electricity.
So the conventional wisdom
was the income elasticity
is greater than 1.
And the price
elasticity is small.
Now, there really wasn't
much historical experience
you could base that on
except the economy had grown.
And if you go back
farther, the figures
get even bigger for
growth in electricity.
But I didn't have
everything back far enough.
The experience was GDP
grows pretty smoothly.
Not much falloff in
electricity in recessions.
So we're looking here at
the long run over decades.
And prices do vary
from time to time
but nobody can see an effect.
So we come now to the '70s.
And there's an oil shock.
And what happens is a
consequence of the oil shock
is all kinds of inputs
to electricity go up.
And instead of declining
faster than other prices,
the price of electricity
is rising faster
than other prices.
So what do you think happened
to the total consumption
of electricity?
How many think it
went up by 1% to 2%?
2% to 3%?
Thank you, Julian.
3 to 4?
How many think we shut
off the electricity?
4 to 5.
Oh, come on.
You've got to vote.
4 to 5, all right.
It went up by 4.
So you immediately say, wow,
income growth actually wasn't
that bad over that period.
There must be more price
sensitivity than we thought.
We got it wrong.
And we were fooled by the fact
that we didn't have much price
variation.
Prices moved and
growth slowed sharply
from those earlier numbers.
So we come now to the
decade of the '80s.
Income growth picks up.
Prices start going down again.
What happens to
electricity growth?
Is it above 4%?
How many think it's above 4%?
How many think it's below 4%?
Some of you think it's
an imaginary number,
I'm missing votes here, OK.
Those who voted
say it's above 4%.
And yet it wasn't.
So now you say, how are
people making these decisions?
There's clearly
some change that's
happened on the
demand side, right?
I mean, something's
different here.
Is it that people were shocked
by the high prices they
encountered and the price
increases they encountered
in the '70s and for the first
time they thought about not
buying every electrical device?
And so you got
slower growth, even
though incomes were growing and
prices were declining a bit--
reasonable hypothesis.
You can test it.
Is there any price
and income effect?
Growth picks up in the '90s.
Prices come down in the '90s
for electricity and other things
as well.
What happens to
electricity demand?
Now, you've got to vote folks.
This is no fun watching people
go, oh, geez, I don't know.
How many think its above 3%?
OK, how many people
think is below 3%?
OK, the smart people win.
It's below 3%.
Why is it below 3%?
Income growth picked up.
Prices started declining
pretty reasonably.
No one quite knows.
You know.
AUDIENCE: A little
earlier on in the years
people were buying more
appliances like refrigerators
and TVs.
And then as you get
into the later years,
everybody already
has those appliances.
But they were getting
more efficient.
And so they're replacing
their existing appliances
with more efficient
appliances and so
electricity use didn't grow.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Maybe, maybe, yeah, it's
not implausible.
You could test it, right?
You could look at purchase
patterns of various appliances.
This is national use.
You're getting the impact
of probably a decline
of manufacturing.
This isn't all residential.
So you're getting
less industrial load.
And you may also be getting
more efficient new construction
in office buildings.
People began to think
about efficiency.
They didn't think
much about efficiency.
But when you start to
think about efficiency,
you begin to get
gains in efficiency.
So I'm guessing its efficiency.
It's not that people stopped
wanting energy services,
but it's kind of implausible
that suddenly you
know, oh, we're going to go
back to small black and white
televisions because
the big colors use
too much electricity.
And I'm willing to
bet refrigerators
didn't shrink over this
period, so probably efficiency.
But I can tell you,
it's a lot easier
to talk about it
after the fact than it
was to see it, to see
it coming on the basis
of historical experience.
Oh, I should take
this after '07.
So this was not a great decade.
And I won't trouble you more.
This is not a great decade.
Income growth slowed.
And if I took it to the end of
the decade, it's really ugly.
Let me not run
into the recession.
But even before the recession,
income growth slowed.
Energy prices began to go up.
And as you might expect,
electricity use slowed as well.
Forecasts out to about
20, 30 show less than 1%
growth a year.
So the business has changed
from one where-- and even
with reasonable economic
growth assumptions--
where 10% and bigger than
that before 1950, 5%, 10%
to maybe 1%.
Maybe 1% over the
next 20 years, OK?
That should have
come up earlier.
That's one caution.
Demand functions are
not constants of nature.
And if anybody says
the elasticity is x,
it probably means the
elasticity has been x.
Or we've got a pretty
good study that estimates
that the elasticity is x.
These are not
constants of nature.
And now let me sort of lead
into the intro to Wednesday.
The earlier discussion of
derived demand and long run,
short run and how
you estimate sort of
assumed in the background
the standard economist model
of rational behavior.
Comes now, McKinsey.
And you've got a very
short McKinsey assignment
on the readings.
McKinsey has made a lot of
money, basically country
to country saying, how
much energy conservation
can be free?
How can you do it for free?
And they do curves like this.
I forget what this one is for.
But this is potential
gigatons of carbon.
But they do it for
energy, as well.
Gigatons of carbon
dioxide reductions
per year and the cost.
And this is all negative.
This is all better than free.
And they have it for
energy consumption.
a bunch of countries.
As I say, they've
made a lot of money.
But they're not the only ones.
Let me not pick on McKinsey,
as much fun as that is to do.
This is called the
efficiency paradox.
And it's been around
since the '70s
that there are lots of
studies that say, look,
you would save money if.
Now, we're going to take a look
at reasons why this persists.
But I will give you an example
I encountered personally.
I came back from Washington,
EPA had just started its Energy
Star program.
I went to people at MIT, and I
said, why not sign up for it?
Why doesn't MIT sign up for the
Energy Star program because A,
you get PR points.
And B, all you promised to do is
to use more efficient lighting
when it saves you money.
You promise to use
more efficient lighting
when it saves you money.
I could not get that sale made.
And nobody's behaving
irrationally,
and nobody's being a jerk.
And we will come
back to it later when
we talk about biodiesel at MIT.
Because it's exactly
the same phenomenon.
Why did it take them three
years to sell biodiesel at MIT.
So we'll talk about that set
of reasons why this persists.
But let me talk
about some others.
I mean, does anyone know
who Amory Lovins is?
OK, Amory Lovins has
been an efficiency guru,
an energy efficiency
guru since the 1970s.
Amory Lovins, he heads the
Rocky Mountain Institute.
He lives in a house that has
quintuple pane glass and highly
insulated.
And I think uses
no outside energy.
And Amory, yeah, you know Amory.
OK.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, well, He
has a super efficient home.
But he can't run the
computer off solar power
so he does actually--
office equipment
he has to get outside help for.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: I'm really
disappointed right there.
Yeah, I'll tell you.
But I was once lobbied
by him in Washington.
And he came in and
explained how there
are all these triple-pane glass
and all these wonderful energy
saving devices that would
more than pay for themselves
and reduce US
energy consumption.
And a guy who was working for
me looked at him and said,
you are saying consumers
save money doing this stuff.
He said, yes, that's right.
And my guy's response
was, that's fabulous.
It means we don't have to
have a government program.
There was a pause.
We'll come back to again.
There ought to be a pause.
But it was a great line.
It was a great line.
He hadn't thought of that.
He has by now.
So why?
Well, one set of answers
in the '70s was these.
And I don't mean
to demean engineers
by saying engineering estimates.
They're sort of back of the
envelope, typical building,
typical household
kind of analysis
that a lot of the early work
was just too optimistic.
It just assumed, you know,
you'd throw out the furnace.
Well, you don't throw
out the furnace.
And you don't save
money by throwing out
a five-year-old furnace
and replacing it early.
So there were a lot of
critiques that said,
these estimates are flawed.
Well, they might be flawed.
But there have been lots
of clear examples later.
The MIT lighting example was an
absolutely dead clear example
of money on the sidewalk,
money on the sidewalk.
So the note sites,
and I think I put
on the list the
Hausman-Joskow paper.
And I say, well, if you look
at consumer decision making--
and Hausman did a classic study
of air conditioners-- consumers
act like they have very
high discount rates.
So you say, can you
rationalize why consumers
don't spend a little more
for energy efficient air
conditioners?
This was using data well
before they were all really
efficient with standards.
How do you rationalize that?
Well, you rationalize
it by saying,
consumers have limited
access to capital.
They don't want to borrow
to buy an air conditioner.
So they act as if their discount
rate is 20%, 30% a year,
which means another
way to think about it,
I need a really quick payback
if I'm going to put money
up front in energy efficiency.
Well, two points, and I'll
come to the second point
in just a minute.
The first point is, that doesn't
explain business behavior.
The 20% to 30% discount rate,
why would a business do that?
If you can raise
capital at let's say
a canonical rate in
the old days of 10%,
and you got an investment
in efficiency that
has a 20% return, why
wouldn't you make it?
You can see the household might
have trouble raising capital
to insulate the house or
to buy air conditioning,
to buy a more efficient
air conditioner.
But Walmart, why
wouldn't Walmart do it?
Well, Walmart probably does.
But why did we seem
to see money lying
on the ground for commercial
and industrial demand?
And we'll see a case later in
the course of an energy saving
opportunity being confronted
by a perfectly rational profit
maximizing firm, high
rate of return that
is a very hard sell.
And we'll see biodiesel
was a very hard sell.
So you got to have
other explanations.
The high discount rate doesn't
make sense for businesses.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yes, would
it make more sense
for the utility
firms to kind of take
charge of going and
trying to make buildings
more efficient in that sense?
They're going to be more
aligned in terms of the profit
they can make because
they'll be using less fuel
for the same sort of
benefit they are going
to provide for the people.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Well, we're
going to come back to that.
It depends on, to
get to that, you
have to have a diagnosis
of the problem.
So if the problem is ignorance,
which is a common argument,
then you say the utility
has better information.
And so it could
probably do this.
Although, the
utilities expertise
is generating electricity,
not cooling buildings, right?
They can acquire the expertise,
but so could some third party.
And some firms do, right?
People do go around.
There are a number of
firms, I'm involved
with one of them that is
trying to make a business out
of selling energy
efficiency to households.
It is not an easy business,
not an easy business.
But the problem with
utilities though--
and we'll come back
to this for sure--
they get compensated
for selling electricity.
So they have an
inherent conflict.
If I can find a way not to rely
on somebody that's conflicted,
I will.
If you say, I'm paying you
for selling electricity now,
I'd like you to go
around and tell people
how to consume less, I'd begin
to wonder how effective you're
going to be.
I can make you do it.
I can make you go around.
And states do this,
but the effectiveness
varies because your motivation
isn't necessarily terrific.
So we've got this low
hanging fruit problem.
And we're going to see this
in a number of settings
that how come opportunities
to increase efficiency
that are apparently profitable
don't get picked up.
But the world is even
more complicated.
Sometimes people over-invest.
Let me talk about the Prius.
How many people or
their parents have
Prius, or relatives have Prius?
Yeah, lots of people have Prius.
And I'm not going to
criticize your rationality
in what I'm saying here, OK?
OK.
So three million
people have bought them
and they sold three
million worldwide.
They've sold over a
million in the US.
I'm now relying on others
who have looked hard at this.
But they tell me that
in terms of driving,
in terms of interior amenities,
the styling is different.
But in terms of interior
design, it's a Corolla.
But it's a Corolla that
gets 50 miles a gallon
instead of 28 miles a gallon.
So let's ask the question,
is it worth the difference
in upfront cost?
Did these three million
people make a good Investment?
Remember, these are people
who are not buying energy
efficient air conditioners.
Well, maybe they are, but
not that many others are.
So let's look at it.
We're going to ask if
the cost difference--
so you save money on gasoline.
A cost difference is the
upfront cost difference.
S is the annual
savings on gasoline.
R is the interest rate.
And T is, how long
do you have to keep
the car until the
savings on gasoline
justify the purchase price.
OK, so that's just a
discounting exercise.
If there's no interest rate,
you just divide the upfront cost
by the annual savings and that
gives you the number of years.
That's 0 interest rate.
If there is a positive
interest rate,
then you ask, you discount
S per year out to T.
And you say, how
large does T have
to be so that discounted savings
equals the original cost.
Clearly if the
savings are small,
there can be no solution.
There can be no positive
solution to this.
But if RC is less than S,
it's this simple formula
you can get in less
than 5 seconds.
So let's look at it.
Toyota, these are
data a few years old.
And they don't
count the subsidies
that were there for the first--
in the US I think it
was 60,000 units sold.
But the subsidies have
long since run out.
So the average premium,
2008, maybe was $7,450.
Assume maintenance is the same.
It may not be.
Prius may be cheaper.
Car's average about
12,000 miles a year.
I can work out the annual cost.
The difference, the
savings is $566.
So if the interest
rate is 0, you've
got to keep the car for
13.2 years to break even.
Now again, if you have a
subsidy or if the gasoline
is more expensive,
this will get smaller.
But that's kind of a long time.
Cars tend to turn over
after about 10, really.
And most people don't
say, hold it for 10.
10 is when they go
out of the fleet.
So if you're going
to resell, you've
got to sell to somebody
who also loves Prius.
If the interest rate
is 5%, not that high,
you've got to hold
the car for 21.6 years
before those gasoline savings
pay for the cost difference.
If the interest rate is above
7.6%, there is no break even.
You can verify that
you don't satisfy that.
So you can hold it forever and
the discounted gasoline savings
don't equal the
original purchase.
Now, you can play with it.
You can put in a
per vehicle subsidy.
You can make gasoline
more expensive.
But these don't seem
like crazy numbers
in light of how those cars work.
And this is the puzzle.
People act when they're
buying air conditioners
like their discount
rate is 20% to 30%.
And they act when they're
buying a Prius like they have
a really low discount rate.
Or maybe this is not the
right way to look at it.
Tell no other
economists I said this.
But it may be that this sort
of economic approach I was
taking here is missing stuff.
It's missing a lot.
Why do people buy
a Prius by the way?
Do people buy a Prius
to save gasoline?
Scot.
AUDIENCE: A lot of people just
buy environmental friendly.
And they want to do something
and something like that.
And so even if it might not
be saving them that much money
or saving them money at
all, they still do it.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: They
want to do the right thing.
There's another
argument that people
make is, there's a reason
the Prius doesn't look
like the Corolla, so not only do
you feel satisfied that you're
doing a good thing, people can
see you're doing a good thing.
Because I mean, that's a funny
looking car to be honest.
And people know you're
driving a Prius.
There are other hybrids you
don't people are driving.
And they don't sell
as well as the Prius.
None of that's here.
The do the good
thing isn't there.
The other people see I'm doing
a good thing isn't there.
This is not the drive demand for
transportation services story
that gets the Prius sold.
This is other things.
And we're going to hear from
professor Silbey on Wednesday
about some of the other things.
Have you questions or comments.
Paper going OK.
Obena.
AUDIENCE: Did they consider
the time saved at the gas pump?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Hmm,
time saved at the gas pump?
AUDIENCE: Right.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
I don't know the size
of the tank on that thing.
Does it save you time?
It probably does.
AUDIENCE: Full time, so that
would be two or three weeks.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
These are people who
value their time very highly.
I have to say, I value
mine really highly.
And it never occurred to me.
But it could be.
It could be you people all
bill out at $1,000 an hour.
And a few minutes
is worth saving.
Any other questions, comments.
David.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
You could also
regulate a small town
than the average driven mile?
So somebody drives less in 2003.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
That might be low.
So maybe it's segments that way.
Also testable.
Sarah, does your
family drive a lot?
AUDIENCE: No, what about risk
aversion and price fluctuations
in gas?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: You figure
this is kind of an insurance
policy that when gas prices
move, we won't be hit too hard.
That's another possibility,
also testable, yeah.
AUDIENCE: I read an article
that production of the Prius
is actually more inefficient
than the production
of the Corolla.
And the energy
that people claimed
they are saving actually
because of the inefficiency
of production, you know, they
established it doesn't actually
save energy.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
So they think
they're doing a good
thing but they're not.
It's a terrible tragedy.
Bring your name cards next time.